[Music]
on this sunday night
israel steps up its attacks on hamas a
defiant prime minister
denies it's politically motivated i
think any country
has to defend itself it has a natural
right of self-defense plus the pressure
on the u.n security council
to end the crisis giving kids their
shots
it will have an incremental benefit on
overall
slowing down transmission the push to
get the next generation
vaccinated the aftermath of liz cheney's
purge
and the future of the republican party
and eroding employee engagement
burnt out canadians decide to leave the
labor force
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us diplomacy appears to be doing little
to stop the hostilities in the middle
east
benjamin netanyahu vows to continue
israel's assault on hamas targets with
full force
the palestinian militant group which
controls the gaza strip
remains defiant firing more than 3 000
rockets into israel
in the past seven days and civilians are
caught in the crossfire
palestinian officials say israeli
strikes have killed nearly 200 people
in gaza israel reports 10 people killed
by hamas rockets
and unicef warns children are bearing
the brunt of the violence
at least 58 children are dead in gaza
and two in
israel the united nations security
council has met publicly for the first
time to discuss the crisis
and as mike armstrong reports there is
immense pressure on the international
community
to intervene and a warning some of the
video you're about to see
is disturbing
on this the seventh day of hostilities
between israel and hamas
there was no rest instead more death
after another night of bombings
palestinians searched through rubble
sometimes finding bodies sometimes
wounded
according to health officials in gaza at
least 42 people were killed sunday
including 10 children on the israeli
side
more civilians caught in the middle of
this conflict a synagogue hit by a hamas
rocket
another landed in damaged vehicles and
one set fire to a field
in the neighborhood of jerusalem that
was the flashpoint for this recent
unrest
seven israeli border officers were
injured sunday when a car
rammed a checkpoint the driver was shot
and killed the moment they were rammed
was captured on video
now israeli officials insist their air
attacks are aimed at military targets
overnight they say they destroyed the
home of a senior hamas leader
it was the third attack going after the
group's leadership in two days
israeli defense forces also say they
were going after a tunnel system used by
hamas
forces underground the explosions and
collapse
took homes down at the same time
civilian casualties they say were
unintentional
good morning mr prime minister thank you
for being with us good morning
appearing on cbs sunday morning israel's
prime minister said hamas has fired
close to 3 000 rockets at his country
ending that threat will take as long as
it takes
we're trying to degrade hamas terrorist
abilities and to degrade their will
to do this again so it'll take some time
i hope it won't take long but
it's not immediate the calls to end the
conflict are coming from just about
every angle there was a meeting of
islamic nations sunday
the pope warned the conflict spiraling
out of control and the un security
council held an emergency meeting
their efforts by both egypt and the u.s
to broker a ceasefire
president biden spoke to prime minister
netanyahu
and president abbas yesterday
neither side seems to be listening to
those calls for calm
one of the leaders of hamas speaking in
cotter this weekend
insisted that in terms of missiles what
the world has seen so far is nothing
compared to what's hidden
but missile supplies appear to be a part
of the equation for israel
an israeli defense official said a
ceasefire now would give hamas time to
recover
letting it continue firing missiles he
says
would deplete its stockpiles and make it
less of a threat
for years mike armstrong global news
to breaking news in toronto one person
is dead and four others have been
injured in a shooting
it happened this afternoon officers were
called after reports a man got out of a
car and began firing into another
vehicle
he then ran away investigators say there
are at least five victims
police say multiple shell casings were
found at the scene
now to the pandemic canada is set to
receive a record four and a half million
doses of vaccine this week
thanks to more early shipments from
pfizer and more of those visor doses
will be going into younger arms
several provinces are starting to
administer shots to kids 12 and up
but how much of that will it make a
difference abigail beeman reports
i've basically just been waiting to get
the vaccine so that i could like feel
safe
going out fourteen-year-old lucas rubick
is one of about a hundred thousand young
people in manitoba
now eligible for a covid19 jab to make
me feel more comfortable but i won't
stop being safe like around other people
health canada gave the green light to
giving children 12 and up the pfizer
vaccine on may 5th
and while all provinces seem to be on
board so far
manitoba and alberta are the only ones
to offer it
saskatchewan and newfoundland and
labrador will start this coming week
ontario quebec and nova scotia promised
first doses before the end of the school
year
while the other three provinces haven't
announced specifics
getting that first dose into these
teenagers
before the end of the school year will
allow for
i think a summer that will be overall
safer for these kids to be able to
engage in
summer camps sporting activities and
other social activities that
really are are important to their
development vaccine teens may be too
late to have an impact on in-person
learning for the end of this school year
but children and parents across the
country are anxiously waiting to hear
whether summer camp will be on
ontario's premier gave some vague hope
during a visit to a vaccine clinic
sunday about the summer camps july 3rd
is usually the time they open they're
opening up this year
because of the great work that these
people are doing
while children have largely not become
seriously ill with kovid
dr jesse pappenberg says they do play a
role in community transmission
especially adolescents it will have an
incremental benefit on overall
slowing down transmission throughout
canada
but it is i don't think we're going to
see a miracle just because we vaccinate
we're able to vaccinate
1.3 million 12 to 15 year olds there's
also the question of vaccine hesitancy
dr pappenberg says he hears concerns
from some people ready to get their own
shot but hesitant to give it to their
kids
he stresses there are strong global
vaccine surveillance systems keeping a
close eye on what happens to children
and says canada will have its own large
study watching for any risks
abigail beeman global news ottawa
medical teams in ontario are working
around the clock to vaccinate adults in
hot spots
the province has set up pop-up clinics
in the hardest hit regions but as
catherine ward explains
there are questions about how the
vaccines will be allocated
in the coming weeks
the two-week push to send more vaccines
to hot spot regions in ontario
has been embraced by people 18 years and
older anxious to roll up their sleeves
and in the final days of this provincial
strategy
scenes of long lineups have been
encouraging signs in the ongoing fight
against covet 19.
the sooner i get vaccinated just like
the safer i feel
an all-night vaccine clinic impeal
region west of toronto
is one of the most recent success
stories as thousands of people
turned out many who can't afford to wait
in line during the day
this is an opportunity for people in
other sectors such as manufacturing and
shift work
taxi drivers truck drivers and alternate
workplaces that just can't come
now the question is what's next for
ontario and how should vaccines be
allocated going forward
the inherent danger is you know that
there's this fall back just to a per
capita location and then this day is
fixed that's what we should avoid dr
peter uni is calling on the province
to be flexible recognizing the needs
will not be the same everywhere
there will be some hot spots that say we
still have enough vaccines and we just
need to make sure that we really
are able to cover our population in this
neighborhood
others might say it's great if we can
continue to have a bit more
and that this should probably be even
individualized other scientists say
achieving targets such as the goal to
vaccinate all
adults before the end of summer
suggested by ontario premier doug ford
will also require some creative thinking
to ensure
no one is left behind so we need to have
these
multi-pronged approaches in order to get
that 75-80 percent capacity
we'll need to look at alternative
strategies so for instance you know
going door to door
might not be as efficient but it may be
a more effective way to reach certain
people
because the worst case scenario would be
having doses and medical teams at the
ready
but no arms to jab catherine ward global
news
toronto india's latest wave of coven 19
cases is showing signs of cresting
but the country's mounting death toll
has led to an unsettling situation
and some of the video you're about to
see is disturbing
hundreds of bodies have turned up in the
famed ganges river poverty and fear of
the disease
are likely reasons why people have
disposed of remains in waterways
crematoriums have been overwhelmed and
there's a shortage of supplies for
traditional funerals
india's neighbor nepal is seeing an
alarming rise in coven 19 cases
in the last 24 hours more than 7 300
people in that country
tested positive for the virus it's
believed the surge is partly due to
cross-border travel between
india and nepal and as redmond shannon
explains
nepal's health care system is not
prepared for the pandemic
a nation gasping for oxygen but this is
not india
this is nepal the country on the roof of
the world is the size of the maritimes
with a population of almost 30 million
its daily case numbers
threaten to surpass anything canada has
seen
its health system is underfunded by any
standard
even compared with its struggling
neighbor india
our hospital has four bentley just four
ventilators
the doctor anesthesiologist who operate
that ventilator
is also infected and is symptomatic he
helped us
on call and by video he helped us
and we try to help the patients
dr rosan choderi says all his critical
care beds
are full we have 54 cases and tested
positive
that's great that's going the graph is
rising every day
it's believed part of the reason for
this current wave
is migrant workers returning home from
india after
lockdown layoffs bringing the virus back
with them
nepal's vaccination rate is currently
around seven percent
the cases are still going to rise and as
the cases rise
already our death rate is going up
a political crisis isn't helping the
current prime minister lost a confidence
vote this week
and is acting as caretaker leader until
a new government is formed
he has pleaded with the g7 nations
including canada
to send aid something nepal's diaspora
is already doing
we are sending 550 cylinders
from oman and we already purchased
about 200 oxygen concentration from
china
and they will be in nepal very soon
within less than a week
toronto nurse chiranjibi gimmera has set
up a gofundme page
to rally nepalese canadians to help buy
more oxygen
and ppe back home his brother is also on
the front line as a doctor
his parents have mild symptoms but in
nepal
they are not deemed sick enough to get
tested for the virus
redmond shannon global news london
coming up a key republican
booted out and the push to keep donald
trump in the spotlight
tonight the future of the republican
party in the u.s is in question
congresswoman liz cheney the daughter of
a former vice president was
booted out of the number three position
her own party turned on her for blasting
donald trump
as jennifer johnson reports it's evident
that the former president
is still pulling the strings a defiant
congresswoman liz cheney is still
publicly blasting former president
donald trump
for spreading lies about the 2020
election and for his role in the january
6th
riot at the capitol it has cost cheney
her leadership role in congress but she
has no regrets
we have to recognize what it means for
the nation to have
a former president who has not conceded
and who continues to suggest that our
electoral system
cannot function cannot do the will of
the people minority leader kevin
mccarthy called for cheney's removal
from house conference chair
after she voted to impeach trump on the
charge of inciting the insurrection that
left five people dead
house republicans took a voice vote no
roll call and in 16 minutes chaney was
replaced
as some republicans downplayed the riot
if you didn't know the tv footage was a
video from january the 6th
you would actually think it was a normal
tourist visit the shake-up has left a
shaken republican party
those still supporting trump versus
those who want their party to move away
from lies and conspiracy theories policy
doesn't matter anymore
it literally is all your loyalty to
donald trump
this is something that like echoes a
little bit out of north korea
chaney's ouster and her replacement are
a clear sign that trump and his
supporters
aren't going away anytime soon i support
president trump
voters support president trump he is an
important voice in our republican party
and we look forward to working with him
cheney had voted for trump's policies
92 percent of the time far greater than
her replacement
congresswoman elise stefanik cheney says
she now regrets voting for trump in 2020
and won't make that mistake again i will
do everything that i can
to make sure he's not the nominee and
you know everything necessary to make
sure that he never gets anywhere close
to the oval office again
chaney the daughter of powerful former
vice president dick cheney
knows she has her work cut out for her
in stopping trump who many believe
will be the republican party's 2024
nominee
jennifer johnson global news washington
rewiring transportation still ahead can
canada get on
board with the electric vehicle
you're watching global national
that need for speed blasted into movie
theaters 35 years ago
top gun became an instant classic in a
quintessential
tom cruise flick when it was released in
1986.
a much older maverick becomes our
wingman once again this fall
the long-awaited sequel is due to be
released in november
it was pushed back because of the
pandemic
over those 35 years a lot has changed in
how we get around
the world is slowly losing that loving
feeling for gas-powered vehicles
many countries are phasing out fossil
fueled cars in favor of electric
but so far canada has rebuffed calls to
commit
our mike chile is taking a look at the
future of electric
mike robin there's an impression here in
canada that we're fairly forward
thinking on issues like the environment
i certainly thought so consider how
we're bombarded on a daily basis with
ads
for electric vehicles that means we're
buying them right
it wasn't so long ago lion bus in san
jerome quebec
was part of the problem founded in 2008
it built school buses and trucks powered
by diesel engines
by 2015 its founder mark badard had had
enough
and he converted his entire line to
electric
it was a calculated risk but he didn't
want to be left behind as the world's
transportation sector was being rewired
what we were saying at lyon is that if
we don't do it now
at some point it's going to be too late
and then the people were saying well
yeah but is it too early
say well maybe 10 years ago
it was too early his move paid off he's
recently inked deals with amazon and
ikea
taking his company public and begun
expansion into the us
the electric revolution is gaining
momentum but canadian consumers
aren't exactly humming the same electric
tune as bedard
3.5 percent of all new vehicles sold in
canada are evs
but that's small compared to the uk
france and germany
uh we're certainly behind some other
countries like norway is the leader in
the world in terms of a heavily
electrified fleet
but the whole world is behind where we
need to be to decarbonize our vehicle
technologies and to decarbonize our
whole transportation fleet so what can
we do to catch up
windsor mp brian massey has been pushing
for the federal government
to be more aggressive with canada's
electric conversion
he wants to see more charging stations
but more than anything he'd like to see
the government invest in canadian
companies
looking to be leaders in ev technology
i don't like the strategies of waiting
around and figuring it out later on
or leaving it to others specifically
what he's talking about are
batteries we may not have a tesla or one
of the big three
ford chrysler or gm to lead our
homegrown manufacturing sector
they're all american companies after all
but what we do have is an abundance of
the materials that go into the
manufacturing of batteries
specifically lithium and this is a
member of the ndp a party
very cautious about environmental issues
saying for us to get
a permanent seat at the ev table we need
to get into mining
robin mike drollet in toronto thanks
mike
when we hear stories about cats and
coyotes
they usually end badly for the cat but a
coyote in bc didn't have a chance
against his feline foe
patrol officers recorded this fearless
kitty chasing a coyote
the cat was victorious running the k-9
right out of the parking lot
and according to police this is not
being cliche the cat came back
the very next day up next
burnt out and time to quit you're not
alone we'll explain when global national
returns
whether it's working from home or taking
on a bigger workload
employees have been going through some
tough changes during this pandemic
the end is starting to come into view
and for many burnt out canadians
they're realizing they may not want to
work at all
as our business correspondent ann
gaviola explains canada may be on the
cusp
of a resignation boom it's really burnt
out
in the fall karen gladdenbar embarked on
what she calls a midlife gap year to
take a break from her family's tech
company
to not have a planned out week or
planned out month
was really scary at first because we're
i'm so used to juggling so many things
and being busy
employment experts say there are scores
of people across canada who want to
leave the workforce
because they're burnt out need to care
for family or want to make a career
change
they've been waiting and thinking about
their exit
the pandemic has caused a lot of
individuals to
really become introspective and
reflective with respect to
not only all aspects of their lives but
certainly with respect to
work according to statistics canada 130
000 people have opted to leave the labor
force
altogether since february 2020 meaning
they're not working and not looking for
work
and their ranks could swell over the
coming months williams advises employers
to clearly communicate what work will
look like along with expectations as the
next normal begins
flexibility can go a long way to keeping
employees
and so can a focus on workplace culture
which has in many cases
suffered during the pandemic just a
little bit on ecosystem
and for employees planning to hand in
their resignation
not burning bridges is important for
future career prospects
you never know when you might cross
paths with a former colleague or boss
and how you resign is just as important
as why you're leaving
don't send an email or a text uh you
know we still should have that
face-to-face
interaction it can only be by a video
conference
you know so be it but you want to show
the respect
although recruiters may not penalize a
career gap during the pandemic the way
they might under normal circumstances
williams suggests having a solid
explanation for why you took time out
by being more available to my kids and
my family
i was able to find little pockets of
time to really get to know them
and for them to get to know me that
weren't planned
or orchestrated so that was probably the
biggest reward
and gaviola global news toronto
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with a wish come
true 21 year old romina asrani has down
syndrome but she always dreamed of
driving a train
well today was that day with the help of
sick kids hospital ramina got her hands
on the controls
during a special tour at toronto's union
station
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and i'll see you next weekend
have a great night
[Music]
you